You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from [inaudible], w.N y.
S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
Okay. So let's just do something. Okay. Off the top of our head. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab, the podcast, podcasts.
And on this podcast just short, we're thinking back to our falling show.
Do you want to just briefly describe that show?
The falling show was a show just to dwell on the word or the idea of falling,
right? So it included falling in love and falling down,
falling over waterfalls in a barrel, falling apart when you're parked, you know,
a place we didn't really get to go in the falling shit,
which I liked to take us. Now they're grabbing,
you know,
the force that makes one fall [inaudible] me.
So no one can really explain why gravity works the way it does,
but we all basically trust that it works. Right?
When you put your foot up in you, you will create the Google, hit the ground,
throw a ball up and in the ground. Yeah. And gravity. And you just get along.
You and gravity have an agreement. Yes,
but we're going to start off with this tail that we ran into.
Amazing tale of a woman who lost that agreement. Oh,
stay the hell away from me. This is actually a true story,
a that comes from an essay written many years ago by a guy named Burton Rue
Shay, who is this great, how would you describe it? Britain Rochet.
He was a great essayist journal of Journalism. Ses.
Yeah. And this essay was published in 1958 in the New Yorker and it's kind of an
interesting essay because it's essentially one long quote from this woman that
burden interviewed Rosemary Morton. It reads like a novel,
even though it's nonfiction. So we asked an actress a, he's been in some movies,
Hope Davis, to read excerpts from Rosemary's story,
and the story begins on a normal night.
Rosemary's at home with her husband, frank, and everything's fine.
[inaudible] for the moment, I've been home about an hour.
Dinner was ready and waiting in the oven and I was sitting at the piano,
not really playing, just amusing myself.
That's something I often do at the end of the day. It helps me relax.
My husband was in the kitchen making us a cocktail,
which is another Morton custom.
We'll usually have a drink or two before dinner.
So everything was quite ordinary and normal until frank came in with the drinks.
I got up to join him on the Sofa and as I did, as I started across the room,
I felt the floor sort of
mm
shake. Is that because there's an earthquake going on?
Well in the essay she looks at frank and she's like, good heavens. I said,
what was that? Frank just looked at me,
his face was a perfect blank. He made some remark
about old buildings stretching and settling and handed me my drink.
[inaudible]
so she doesn't really think too much of this cause it was very momentary. Okay.
But a week later she's at work. She's asking the library,
cause she's a librarian. She's at her desk.
I worked at my desk for about an hour and he was having so quiet, so peaceful.
Yeah.
Then I got up to get a book from the stacks or a drink of water or something and
it happens. The floor,
a shake
and sank. It went down on up just one
lurch, maybe a little more pronounced than the first time,
and then everything was back to normal
suck for my state of mind. I didn't know what to think the best
do was tell myself that this was an old building too. It was built around nine
1500 so that was your sense at first,
just old buildings.
It never occurred to me that there might be any other explanation.
I suppose I didn't want it to,
but then over the next few days, very odd things began to happen.
I don't know how to describe it,
but I had the feeling that my sense of touch was getting more and more acute,
especially in the souls of my feet.
I could feel a little tremors,
no,
that other people couldn't.
Wow.
I didn't tell frank until the middle of the following week on Wednesday night to
be exact. By then I had to,
I couldn't keep it to myself any longer.
There was something wrong with me.
Ooh,
there just wasn't any word for the awful sensations I've been having.
The floor shaking feeling was only one of them.
I don't know how many times that happened over the weekend.
Seven or eight at least. But even that began to have a different feeling.
At first the floor had moved or sagged as a whole.
It still did.
Only now I could feel another movement to kind of counter that.
Sometimes it was as if I were sinking into the floor.
The room would tilt and I take a step and the floor was like snow.
It would give under my foot and I would sink
[inaudible]
and other times it was just the reverse. A floor would rise up to meet me.
By then,
it wasn't simply the floor that moved when the floor tilted the walls of the
room tilted with it and the ceiling, I mean the shape of the room never changed.
Only its position in space.
Okay,
so rosemary went to see her doctor and her doctor, her just some specialists,
and they ran some tests and then a short while later she went back to her doctor
to get the results. He read me their conclusions and they were all the same.
They even used the same phrase, impression,
essentially normal.
I'll never forget that phrase. Normal, essentially normal
[inaudible].
It sounds so reassuring, so comforting,
but it isn't. At least it wasn't to me. It was terrifying.
After this diagnosis or non diagnosis,
things really take a turn. Fast forward a few months.
There were times in March and early April when I was absolutely certain I was
going to die,
but my reaction to death was peculiar.
I don't remember feeling afraid.
All I remember is an overwhelming sense of urgency.
So little time, so little done so much I wanted to do
okay.
I dragged frank to the theater more than once and I never thought of refusing
when he suggested the philharmonic or the metropolitan.
My response to music has never been so complete.
I spent hours listening to records.
I'd play some old favorites like Beecham conducting Haydn's London symphony and
it was amazing.
[inaudible]
seem to me that I could hear the inner structure more clearly than ever before.
So the idea of a dinner and a concert wasn't at all
the usual.
My only mistake was to take that dreadful underground passage
[inaudible]
it was raining and I was in a hurry,
but even so I should've realized when I did it was too late. Wait,
the passage was jammed with commuters shoving,
pushing and surging towards me, but I didn't dare to.
Fluor was beginning to wobble and I knew if I tried to swing around,
it would tip me head over heels. All I could do was go on.
The traffic was still all against me. People kept looming up, towering up.
The came charging at me like John
[inaudible]
and then I felt something right out of a nightmare.
I was almost at the end of the passage when I felt the movement change
[inaudible]
it was as if someone had pulled 11
there was a little jolt
and the floor was moving very slowly backwards down the passage.
I was walking on a treadmill only for a minute though.
Then I reached the stairs.
I drove myself up to the lobby and collapsed in a chair.
I was jelly
mm mm.
From early April, I began to move in a different world.
I was conscious of a new dimension, a new plane.
I had a new relationship to space, my legs,
my arms, my face. My whole body felt different.
It had no permanent shape.
It changed by the minute I seem to be completely at the mercy of some outside
force, some atmospheric pressure.
I was a morphous.
My left leg would seem to lengthen or my right arm or my neck.
Oh one whole side of me. It would double or triple in size,
and yet that doesn't fully describe it.
There were times when the forest seemed to be the rotation of the earth.
I would have the feeling that I was vertically aligned with the Earth's axis.
I could feel a sort of winding movement startup inside me.
Then one of my legs would begin to shorten as if it were an anchor being drawn
slowly up by a week.
The other leg would dangle after a minute. The winch,
which shift it would engage the dangling like and justice slowly bring it up to
match the other
[inaudible]
just feels like I'm kind of a nightmare cartoon of some kind. Yeah. So, so what,
what is it, what is wrong with her? Well, after months of this,
at the end of the year essay,
she does finally learn that this condition she has has an aim.
My trouble was a disturbance of the internal ear called labyrinthitis labyrinth
hiatus. The suffix [inaudible] meant inflammation, swelling.
So the meaning of Librarian situs as a word was simply an inflammation of the
oral labyrinth. You know,
I think people in science and medicine love to give big fat names to,
I don't know. Well actually this condition you should know goes by another name.
What? Vertigo. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
that's why I liked the story cause like I didn't know,
I mean like I always thought a vertigo like from the movie. Yeah.
Like you're on a stairs and you're like, yeah,
Woo.
Like it's just a thing with heights, you know,
like that's what it was in the Hitchcock film.
But what Rosemary Morton goes through in this story,
it's like it seems way deeper.
And at some point in the essay,
she actually refers to her situation as a case of gravitational anarchy.
That's an interesting phrase. I kinda, I kinda like, yeah,
well does she get better? Yup. It's impossible to say exactly what it all ended,
but I think it was frank who really sensed it first. It was after
dinner one night in late August and he suddenly smiled and remarked that I must
be feeling much better. I asked him what he meant.
You never look scared anymore.
He said it, it's very mysterious,
but your vertigo just went away without explanation for the coming and no
explanation for the going. Some things just don't have explanations, Robert,
but they have wonderful sound design
and that's Radiolab. No explanation. It's pretty salads.
I buy it, taking the vitamins. I am crazy for founders,
just speaking of not knowing anything. Um, a few weeks ago on this very program,
we decided to take up the question of falling, you know, falling in love,
falling apart, all that. And one of our topics at which we did with the,
the great,
I have to say this now with a certain fierceness because of what's about to
happen with the great journalist David Quam.
And we were talking about falling cats.
And just to summarize the whole thing started for David and therefore for us
when he read this study written by two vets,
Wayne Whitney and Cheryl Mel Hoff who worked in um,
the mid town veterinary hospital and they noticed that, um,
that in Manhattan there were a lot of cats falling out of windows high windows,
falling off ledges falling off roofs. And when they looked at the data,
they found something a little strange that cats who fell on the first two fifth
floors were lightly injured, which makes sense.
Cats that felt from the 10th floor up. They also didn't get hurt so much,
which doesn't make sense. It's cats who fell from the fifth to the ninth floor.
Those were the ones that really got banged up.
And we thought this was super interesting.
I mean like why would a cat falling 42 floors not get hurt more than a cat
falling nine floors doesn't make any sense.
And David gave us what we thought it was a very plausible answer,
but it was one that made a lot of listeners go,
hmm, I'm not buying it. Like Ryan said, that guy, that's Neil degrasse Tyson,
astrophysicist frequent guests. I laid out the general idea of the program.
We said they had, I dunno. Was it six? How many cats?
Oh boy. I don't remember cats. This building was hundreds, but it was, no, no,
it was hung. Those two was, yeah. Only hundreds of cats. You want,
you want a bigger number? You Ain't no, I'm just a hundreds. Yes, that's a lot.
They kept a careful, uh, sort of record.
It's hundreds of cats who fell and were taken to the vet. That's right.
That's a different number. Right?
The ones who died didn't probably get taken to the hospital or the ones who
survived without need of medical care. Well, it's too bad, Phil,
from the 40th floor. Wouldn't you take him to the doctors?
He stands up and does the Jig. No, it's fun. Catch up. Nine lies.
So this is a highly biased dataset among all cats that fell from a window of the
cats who fell we or rather these vets noticed the cats who fell and were taken
to the vet. So I'm betting that the high floors, most of them just simply died.
And you don't take a dead cat to the vet. I mean you might, but why? All right,
so you started with completely biased sample.
So I don't,
I try not to spend much brain power analyzing flawed data.
Okay. We can deal with that.
Okay. That's our guy in the fight. That's David Coleman.
Clearly Dr. Tyson, ease of, he's a smart guy,
but Tyson is missing the point.
I think the point is within this admittedly biased sample,
there's a really,
really interesting pattern that begs to be explained and that is among the cats
that have fallen and have gotten injured somewhat,
the ones that sell five stories got injured worse than the ones that fell 25
stories. Why?
That's an interesting question. No matter how many cats died,
there's still this interesting skew in the injured cat population that's not
going away.
And he's saying your Dataset is incomplete.
And what I say in response is it's a very interesting dataset and let's try and
understand it.
Incomplete or not.
All data sets are incomplete. What is, what does he study?
He studies physics. Yeah.
Did he study stars? Distant stars.
Justin star is actually an astrophysicist.
Oh, okay. Well he's looked at a few
dark
and he's drawn conclusions about him based on what he's seen.
Well wait, let me back up. If your data though,
incomplete suggested something that made sense, given the laws of physics,
then you'd have less urge to question it.
But you're telling me something that conflicts with my understanding of Physics
One oh one we haven't yet told you. But I'll tell you where.
Got To tell you now, let me tell you it. No, no. So you invent and you invent
[inaudible] I feel an invention come back to the, well, I feel alive.
We need to call a perfectly reasonable interpretation.
But what you might call it, an invention goes as follows. So
the cat falls out of the 42nd floor window, let's say,
and it begins to accelerate. So for one, two, three, four,
five floors, it is accelerating.
And then something happens around nine floors where the pole of gravity gets
balanced out by the push of the air against its belly and it hits terminal
velocity, which irregular words is it? It's continued to drop at the same speed.
So then it's at cruising speed.
After the cat's hit terminal velocity and the sensation of acceleration was
gone, they relaxed
[inaudible],
they sort of stretch out like a flying squirrel
and then they hit the ground belly flop.
And you're saying that because they hit the screws and speed and then relax into
the flying squirrel? The impact is less.
Yes.
There's no obvious reason to me why a cat at terminal velocity is more relaxed
than a cat. In Free Fall, you're essentially in free fall, you're weightless,
you're, you're weightless. Your speed actually doesn't matter.
While you're weightless, you don't even know what you're speeding.
What do you mean? Well, you're speeding up. So things are changing.
If you're speeding up, it is an unnoticeable phenomenon. Yeah.
The cat is as weightless at the moment. They leave the window as they are,
as they approached the, the terminal velocity speed.
Do you have a cat by the way? No, but I, I've, I've,
I've explored the behavior of cats. Okay.
Under the laws of physics in my youth violence,
but just I'm learning, I said discretely look away.
So, uh,
the cat freaks instantly when there's no ground under it,
it gets its legs underneath within a fraction of a second after that.
Now you try to go psycho on the cat and say, oh,
well it's thinking about it's fall and it's free. It's accelerating.
Then it's in terminal velocity. It's already legs pointed down at that point.
Well, um,
the part about you are essentially weightless when you're falling.
Whether you're accelerating or not is something that he's more likely to know
about than we are. And I, I give him credit for that.
On the other hand, he's a physicist. He's not an animal behaviorist,
so he really doesn't know any better than we do what a cat thinks or what a cat
feels.
Probably there are a lot of cat owners out there who could help us as much as
this, um, brainy, brainy physicist.
So maybe we should ask our listeners,
but ladies and gentlemen,
do not approach this as an experimentally addressable yes.
Question. Do not throw your cat out of a window. Do not do that.
We will come into rescue if you do that.
One of the things that makes us kind of a tricky, um, opaque,
intractable question.
So here's what we suggest. We should cast it.
You go to your cat if you have one, if you speak cat, just ask them. Tell me.
It's accelerating. Different from just lighting to the ground.
Do you know the famous Cat Jelly toast experiment? No. What's that?
It's your cat always lands on its feet, right?
A slice of Jelly toast always lands jelly side down.
So you should have trap jelly toast to the back of a cat thinking they might
cancel each other at.
And so there's a research paper on it that says you take the cat with the jelly
toast trapped on his bed, and then you toss it and it falls,
and then it stops. Then it hovers above the ground
and just illustrate the land. There's no, no,
it doesn't land at all because it can't know which way to learn.
It's the jelly toast is fighting the urge to land on its feet.
This is a well known experiments and the Journal of irreproducible results
are such a result. Belongs Gary, let's get out of here.
Thank you to Neil degrasse Tyson subject. Here's the six.
You actually have the Hayden Planetarium. Thank you to David Quammen,
Big d and uh, thank you Robert. Thank you jack
gravity. And while we're giving thanks, um, thanks to Burton roof, Shea
[inaudible], he's not alive anymore, but uh,
but you can find his story essentially normal in the awesome book medical
detectives, which was published in 1984 by Dutton.
Our sincere thanks to actress Hope Davis and to Sarah Montague and Ellen Horn
for directing hope in the studio.
And thanks to Tim Howard and Douglas Smith for, uh,
the scoring help with that piece. And lastly, thanks to you for listening.